Я головую на подібних подіях багато
разів, як ви знаєте, протягом багатьох років, і я
дійсно можу сказати, що ця подія змінила
ситуацію, тому що вперше, на
жаль, ми сподіваємося, що також, і у нас були
нові люди, у нас були віддані люди, і
ми були дуже свіжими  ідеї багато чого
відбувається і зараз в Україні, чого
не було в попередні терміни, звичайно, і
я б не обмежував свою думку, і тільки
сьогодні їх спільний комітет, що також
вчорашня конференція з міністрами
з багатьма президентами науки
обох країн була  справжня
подія на планеті, і це дало надію на Україну та
на нашу співпрацю, на вашу думку,
яка стратегічна жорстка співпраця
між Німеччиною, у нас дуже хороша
давня співпраця між нашими
науковими спільнотами і, звичайно,
співпраця зараз
кажуть, пов'язана з обмеженнями у вашій
країні  давайте, бюджетна ціна також
підтверджується на шляху, що робить його
захоплюючим, я б сказав, тому що ми не
знаємо, що одна людина буде
результатом o  щодо нових законодавчих реформ, які
знаходяться в наших ложах та підґрунтях, які знаходяться
на шляху до створення, я просто сподіваюся,
що Україна знайде розумний
шлях між залученням усіх зацікавлених сторін
у країні та реальними
процесами реформ та, з іншого боку,
усвідомленням того, що  Ви не можете говорити з усіма
в той час, коли ми є проблемою в
Німеччині, кажучи, якщо у вас буде занадто
багато кухарів, ви ніколи не отримаєте вже
меню, і я сподіваюся, що тропіки,
професійні,
були шляхом для країни, і я  Я дуже
впевнений у тому, що наступного року
вже буде інша ситуація. Я
хочу задати одне коротке запитання, і, будь ласка, уявіть, будь ласка,
трішки уявіть його попереднє
колесо огляду змінного струму
чи це в науці та дослідженнях це
можливо, звичайно, я можу назвати
дозвілля та майбутню співпрацю, де ми
знаходимо досконалість у Німеччині та знаходимо
партнерів та знайшли партнерів в
Україні  e, звичайно, це наука про матеріал,
це біотехнологія,
нанотехнологія, і тому, на жаль, я маю
багато ознак,
які відкладаються
та обмежуються через політичну
ситуацію, про яку ми сьогодні дізналися, що промисловість дорогоцінних каменів
дуже прагне відкрити нові
місця для морських досліджень.  Я дуже
зацікавлений у цій співпраці, і я
не можу завершити свою відповідь, тому що
жодна з дорогих країн не може визначити,
які будуть справжні національні
пріоритети, і я з нетерпінням чекаю
прихованих